How many of you have watched a horror movie this month, or decorated your lawn with skeletons and zombies, or visited a haunted corn maze? October may be the month that our fixation on things ghoulish, grisly, and scary, reaches a peak. But for many people, a fascination with the darker side of life isn't limited to Halloween. Some of us love being scared out of our wits all year long. There are a dozen Friday the 13th movies, the Scream franchise released its sixth film this year, And a list of the top 25 podcasts in the U.S. include shows called crime junkie, morbid, and my favorite murder. Clearly, there's a big appetite out there for horror, true crime, and other types of terrifying entertainment.
你们中有多少人这个月看过恐怖电影，或者用骷髅和僵尸装饰过草坪，又或者去过闹鬼的玉米迷宫？十月可能是我们对那些阴森、恐怖和吓人事物痴迷程度达到顶峰的月份。但对许多人来说，对生活阴暗面的迷恋并不局限于万圣节。我们中的一些人一年到头都喜欢被吓得魂飞魄散。市面上有十几部《13号星期五》电影，《惊声尖叫》系列今年也上映了第六部，而美国排名前25的播客列表中包括了《犯罪迷》、《病态》和《我最爱的谋杀》等节目。显然，大众对恐怖、真实犯罪以及其他类型的惊悚娱乐有着巨大的胃口。
So why is that? Why do we love to scare ourselves silly? Are there certain personality traits that people who are drawn to horror, true crime, and other scary genres share? And are those people onto something? Could watching horror movies be good for our mental health? Can scary entertainment improve our well-being and leave us better equipped to handle real-life challenges? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Colton Scrivener, a behavioral scientist at the Recreational Fear Lab
那么这是为什么呢？为什么我们喜欢把自己吓个半死？那些被恐怖、真实犯罪和其他惊悚类型吸引的人是否拥有某些共同的人格特质？这些人是否发现了什么门道？看恐怖电影对我们的心理健康有好处吗？惊悚娱乐能改善我们的幸福感，让我们更有能力应对现实生活中的挑战吗？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是来自丹麦奥胡斯大学“娱乐性恐惧实验室”的行为科学家、亚利桑那州立大学的项目研究经理科尔顿·斯克里文纳博士。
at Urhus University in Denmark and a research project manager at Arizona State University. He studies the psychological underpinnings of our fascination with the darker side of life, including horror, true crime, and all types of scary play. He's also interested in how morbid curiosity relates to personality and mental health. Dr. Scrivener has published research on morbid curiosity and scary play in scientific journals, including psychological science and nature scientific reports, and has been interviewed by media outlets such as the New York Times, the Washington Post, the Wall Street Journal, and NPR.
他在丹麦奥胡斯大学“娱乐性恐惧实验室”工作，同时也是亚利桑那州立大学的项目研究经理。他研究我们对生活阴暗面（包括恐怖、真实犯罪和各种惊悚游戏）迷恋背后的心理学基础。他还对病态好奇心如何与人格和心理健康相关联感兴趣。斯克里文纳博士在《心理科学》和《自然-科学报告》等科学期刊上发表过关于病态好奇心和惊悚游戏的研究，并接受过《纽约时报》、《华盛顿邮报》、《华尔街日报》和美国国家公共电台（NPR）等媒体的采访。
He's working on a book about the science morbid curiosity to be published next year. Dr. Skrivenor, thank you for joining me today. Hi, Kim. Thank you for having me on. So how do you define morbid's curiosity? You've developed a scale to measure it. What kinds of things do you ask about? Yeah, that's a good question,
他正在撰写一本关于病态好奇心科学的书，将于明年出版。斯克里文纳博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。你好，金。谢谢你邀请我。那么，您是如何定义“病态好奇心”的？您已经开发了一个量表来衡量它。您会问些什么样的问题呢？是的，这是一个好问题，
because that was actually the first problem I came across when I started studying it, is that there wasn't a great definition of it, or at least there wasn't kind of an agreed-upon definition. So after a bit of research, the definition that I landed on was that morbid curiosity is simply a curiosity or an interest in things that are potentially dangerous. So that could be things that are fictionally dangerous that kind of tap into our minds a little bit or things that are actually dangerous, like the things we read on the news or hear about from others. Have you found that most people are at least a little morbidly curious? How wide is the range?
因为这实际上是我开始研究它时遇到的第一个问题，那就是它没有一个很好的定义，或者至少没有一个公认的定义。所以在做了一些研究后，我得出的定义是：病态好奇心仅仅是对潜在危险事物的某种好奇或兴趣。这可能包括那些虚构的危险，它们在某种程度上触动了我们的思维；也可能是那些现实中真实的危险，比如我们在新闻中读到或从他人那里听到的事情。您是否发现大多数人至少有一点病态好奇心？这个范围有多广？
Yeah, I think morbid curiosity is sometimes talked about as if it's this fringe trait or a fringe thing that only some people have. But in all the research I've done, if you give people, for example, the morbid curiosity scale, you find that morbid curiosity is pretty normally distributed, meaning that most people have a pretty moderate amount of morbid curiosity. Some people have a lot and some people have a little bit. And this has been true not just in the U.S. but in other countries as well as well. including Canada, Brazil, Denmark, and several other countries that have taken this test. Let's talk about horror specifically. For people who don't like watching horror movies, and that does not include me. I like a good, scary movie.
是的，我认为人们有时谈论病态好奇心，就好像它是一种只有少数人才有的边缘特质或边缘事物。但在我所做的所有研究中，如果你给人们做“病态好奇心量表”测试，你会发现病态好奇心的分布是非常正常的，这意味着大多数人都有相当适度的病态好奇心。有些人很多，有些人很少。这不仅在美国是这样，在其他国家也是如此，包括加拿大、巴西、丹麦以及其他几个参与过这项测试的国家。让我们专门谈谈恐怖片。对于那些不喜欢看恐怖电影的人来说——这不包括我，我喜欢看好的恐怖片——
It can be hard to understand why so many other people love them. What have you found in your research? Why do people enjoy watching horror flicks? So the traditional answer from psychology about why people have enjoyed, watching horror films has been that simply because they're adrenaline junkies. And one of the first things I looked into is whether or not this assumption was true, because there were kind of a few studies in the 1980s that looked at this, kind of when the slasher genre became popular, people got interested in this question.
可能很难理解为什么其他人会那么喜欢它们。您在研究中发现了什么？为什么人们喜欢看恐怖片？心理学界关于人们为什么喜欢看恐怖片的传统答案是：他们单纯是“肾上腺素瘾君子”。我研究的第一件事就是这个假设是否正确，因为在20世纪80年代，当砍杀电影类型流行起来时，人们对这个问题产生了兴趣，当时有一些研究探讨过这一点。
You know, the psychological tools that were available, especially in personality science, weren't as robust in the 80s and one as varied and widely distributed in the 80s as they are now. And so what I've found is that, yes, there are some people who enjoy horror because they are high in something called sensation seeking. They like the feelings of strong sensations. These are the same kind of people that would go bungee jumping or skydiving or any number of things like that that kind of give you an adrenaline boost. However, it seems to be actually only a small portion of the horror fan base. So, for example, one of the studies we conducted at a haunted attraction during Halloween,
你知道，80年代可用的心理学工具，特别是在人格科学方面，并不像现在这样稳健、多样且广泛分布。所以我发现，是的，确实有些人喜欢恐怖片是因为他们属于“寻求刺激”型人格。他们喜欢强烈感觉带来的快感。这些人就像那些会去蹦极、跳伞或做任何类似事情的人一样，这些活动能给你带来肾上腺素的激增。然而，这似乎只占恐怖片粉丝群的一小部分。例如，我们在万圣节期间的一个闹鬼景点进行的一项研究，
found that even at this high intense situation of scary play, like a haunted house, only a small number of people are adrenaline junkies or sensation seekers. And the remainder of them actually are pretty afraid before and actually feel genuinely scared when they go through the haunted house. And so, of course, we asked, well, why are they there if they're genuinely afraid and don't necessarily love the adrenaline rush for the adrenaline rush's sake? And what we found were that a lot of people feel as if they learn something about themselves and sort of develop as a person through these experiences.
发现即使在这种高强度的惊悚游戏情境下，比如鬼屋，也只有少数人是肾上腺素瘾君子或寻求刺激者。其余的人在进入鬼屋之前其实非常害怕，在里面时也确实感到真正的恐惧。所以，我们当然会问，如果他们真的感到害怕，且并不一定是为了肾上腺素而追求肾上腺素，那他们为什么还要去呢？我们发现，许多人觉得通过这些经历，他们了解了关于自己的一些事情，并在某种程度上得到了成长。
And so you hear about this in real tragedies a lot, this kind of post-traumatic growth or I'm glad I went through this so that I, because I learned something and I grew as a person. And it seems like different kinds of scary plays, such as even just watching a horror movie or if you're a small child like playing hide-and-seek or playing scary imaginative games. These can help you kind of feel out the sort of limits of your fear and what you're able to handle. And they kind of, in many cases, can give you sort of self-confidence that you can overcome things that feel scary. But is there a point where fear is no longer healthy? Or do most people who like to watch horror movies know when it might be causing them more stress than enjoyment?
你在真实的悲剧事件中经常听到这种说法，即所谓的“创伤后成长”，或者“我很高兴我经历了这些，因为我学到了东西，我作为一个人的成长了”。似乎各种各样的惊悚游戏，比如仅仅是看一部恐怖电影，或者如果你是一个小孩，玩捉迷藏或玩恐怖的想象游戏，这些都能帮助你感受恐惧的极限以及你能够应对的程度。在许多情况下，它们能给你一种自信，让你相信自己可以克服那些让你感到害怕的事情。但是，恐惧是否有一个不再健康的临界点？或者大多数喜欢看恐怖电影的人是否知道什么时候它可能带来的压力多于享受？
It's tricky, I think, to know. I mean, that's probably true of most things in life, right? It's too much of a good thing is always a bad thing, right? And certainly the same is true of scary play or fear. I do think people have a good intuition about when enough is enough, right? Like when they're too scared and they no longer have a good grip on like, you know, that the best kind of scary play, you have kind of one foot in reality and one foot in this imaginary world where you're sort of letting things scare you. And when we go through experiences like haunted houses or horror movies or we read a scary book,
我认为这很难判断。我的意思是，这对于生活中的大多数事情来说可能都是如此，对吧？过犹不及，这总是不好的，对吧？当然，惊悚游戏或恐惧也是如此。我确实认为人们对于“适可而止”有一种很好的直觉，对吧？比如当他们太害怕，以至于无法很好地掌控局面时——你知道，最好的惊悚游戏是让你一只脚踏在现实中，另一只脚踏在这个让你感到害怕的虚构世界里。当我们经历鬼屋、恐怖电影或阅读恐怖书籍时，
we kind of tow that line, right? And we're partly at the whims of the narrator of the creator of the game. And when things get too scary and we get pushed too much into that imaginary world, we perform certain actions that help draw us back in. So for example, in some of the studies I've done, we found that people will actually suppress their fear
我们是在走钢丝，对吧？我们部分受制于叙述者或游戏创作者。当事情变得太可怕，我们被推入那个虚构世界太深时，我们会采取某些行动来帮助自己回到现实。例如，在我做的一些研究中，我们发现人们实际上会抑制自己的恐惧，
if they get too scared. So they'll cover their eyes. They'll imagine that it's not real. They'll sort of avert their attention to something else or cover their ears. They'll do things to kind of dull the sensations. And if they're not scared enough, they'll do things to actually heighten the sensations. They'll immerse themselves a bit more.
如果他们感到太害怕的话。他们会捂住眼睛，想象这不是真的，他们会把注意力转移到别处或捂住耳朵。他们会做一些事情来减轻这种感觉。如果他们觉得不够害怕，他们会做一些事情来增强这种感觉。他们会让自己沉浸得更深一些。
They'll, you know, look at the scare actors in a haunted house, or they will let themselves scream when they're feeling afraid. And so people do kind of regulate their arousal and regulate their immersion to hit this kind of sweet spot when they're watching horror movies and going through haunted houses and even listening to True Crime Podcasts. So are you a horror movie fan yourself? I am. I'm probably I'm probably not as big of a fanatic.
他们会，你知道，盯着鬼屋里的惊悚演员看，或者在感到害怕时让自己尖叫出来。所以人们确实在调节自己的唤醒水平和沉浸感，以便在看恐怖电影、逛鬼屋甚至听真实犯罪播客时达到这种“甜蜜点”。那么您自己是恐怖电影迷吗？我是。我可能……我可能没有大家想象的那么狂热。
people assume I am. I mean, I do love horror movies. I am a, I would consider myself a, definitely a horror fan. But I kind of fell into this line of research accidentally. It's, you know, it wasn't that I was a horror fan and decided I needed to study that. It was more just, I was a horror fan and I was interested in these paradoxical things that humans do. And one of those things is that we scare ourselves for fun. Do you have a favorite horror movie yourself? And are Are there horror movies that you would consider more therapeutic than others? Ooh, more therapy. I mean, you know, to the extent that a scary story can help you sort of work through things
人们假设我是。我的意思是，我确实喜欢恐怖电影。我是一个，我会认为自己绝对是一个恐怖片粉丝。但我有点偶然地进入了这个研究领域。你知道，并不是因为我是恐怖片粉丝，所以决定去研究它。更多是因为我是一个恐怖片粉丝，并且对人类所做的这些矛盾的事情感兴趣。其中之一就是我们为了好玩而吓唬自己。您自己有最喜欢的恐怖电影吗？有没有您认为比其他电影更具治疗作用的恐怖电影？噢，更具治疗作用。我的意思是，你知道，如果一个恐怖故事能帮助你解决一些问题，
and conquer your fears, I think that depends on the person because some people have a higher threshold for fear and some people have a lower threshold for fear. So there probably isn't a good sort of single movie out there or single game out there for that. As far as my favorite, I mean, I really love the... The Haunting of Hill House, which is actually, I guess, a mini-series, not a, not a movie. But it's a really great example of sort of long-form scary story and long-form storytelling and horror. The Autopsy of Jane Doe is another really great one.
并克服你的恐惧，我认为这取决于个人，因为有些人对恐惧的阈值较高，有些人较低。所以可能没有一种单一的电影或游戏适合所有人。至于我最喜欢的，我的意思是，我真的很喜欢……《鬼入侵》，这其实，我想是一部迷你剧，而不是电影。但它是长篇恐怖故事和长篇叙事的一个非常好的例子。《尸检无名女尸》是另一部非常棒的作品。
After I watched that, I realized that it incorporated a lot of elements from my work on morbid curiosity that, you know, kind of had these different facets that I'd been studying, kind of all smashed into one movie. Yeah, probably those two would be my story. my favorites. Well, let's talk about some other scary genres like true crime podcasts or TV shows like you just mentioned. What about these programs and podcasts that are about serial killers? Do people enjoy those for the same reasons?
看完那部电影后，我意识到它结合了我关于病态好奇心研究中的许多元素，你知道，它把我一直在研究的这些不同侧面都融合进了一部电影里。是的，大概这两部是我的最爱。好吧，让我们谈谈其他惊悚类型，比如您刚才提到的真实犯罪播客或电视节目。关于这些讲述连环杀手的节目和播客，人们是因为同样的原因喜欢它们吗？
Or is there something else going on psychologically? I think that they can enjoy them for the same reasons. True crime tends to be a little bit less in your face with the violence and gore and horror movies tend to lean into that a little bit more. And so horror movies lend themselves to, you know, adrenaline rushes a bit more easily if that's what you're after. However, a lot of people who watch or read or listen to true crime also get very scared from it often times after the fact when they're at home alone later or, you know,
还是说心理上还有其他原因？我认为他们可以因为同样的原因喜欢它们。真实犯罪节目在暴力和血腥方面往往不那么直接，而恐怖电影往往更倾向于这一点。因此，如果你追求的是肾上腺素激增，恐怖电影更容易满足这一点。然而，许多观看、阅读或收听真实犯罪节目的人，往往在事后独自在家时，或者，你知道，
when they're thinking about it later. But I think people do derive a lot of the same pleasures out of it. That is this kind of pleasure of learning about something, right? I mean, learning is intrinsically rewarding. I think there are quite a few studies that have shown that across a variety of different circumstances. And I think learning about threats is especially rewarding because, you know, your brain sort of feels like it's getting a good deal because you're safe, yet you're learning about something that typically would be very costly to learn about. So if you're listening to a true crime podcast or watching a, you know, a docu-series about a serial killer, your brain sort of cataloging all these things about what kind of clear. did the police miss or what kind of clues did their friends and family miss?
当他们稍后思考这些内容时，也会感到非常害怕。但我认为人们确实从中获得了许多同样的乐趣。那就是学习某种东西的乐趣，对吧？我的意思是，学习本身就是一种内在的奖励。我认为有不少研究表明，在各种不同的情况下都是如此。而且我认为学习威胁尤其具有奖励性，因为，你知道，你的大脑会觉得它做了一笔好买卖，因为你是安全的，但你却在学习一些通常需要付出巨大代价才能学到的东西。所以，如果你在听一个真实犯罪播客或看一个关于连环杀手的纪录片系列，你的大脑会整理所有关于“警察错过了什么线索”或“他们的朋友和家人错过了什么线索”的信息。
And you're sort of creating this rolodex of behaviors and attitudes and traits that serial killers might have. And that can feel very rewarding. So I want to talk for a little bit about your morbid curiosity test, which is available on the web for anybody who wants to know where they fall on the continuum. And just to out myself here, I came in at 3.96 out of a 5, which is a little bit higher than the end. average, which I think is 3.41. I found it interesting that you included so many questions about things that are really gory, like whether you'd want to watch a head transplant if such a thing were possible, or attend a public execution in the Middle Ages, or watch an autopsy.
你正在建立一个连环杀手可能具备的行为、态度和特质的索引。这会让人感觉非常有成就感。我想谈谈您的“病态好奇心测试”，它在网上对任何想知道自己在连续体上处于什么位置的人开放。顺便透露一下，我的得分是3.96分（满分5分），这比平均分3.41分要高一点。我发现有趣的是，您包含了许多关于非常血腥事物的问题，比如如果可能的话，是否想看换头手术，或者参加中世纪的公开处决，或者观看尸检。
And it seems to me that there's a really big difference between seeing something gross in a movie or a TV show and seeing it in real life. Is there a strong connection between the two, horror and gore, because I have to say, it seems to me that it's, it's pretty unhealthy to want to watch these gory things. So why do you link the two? Well, I think you could say that about probably a lot of different things that, depending on your motivations for watching it, right? So if I, let's say I enjoy boxing or MMA, millions and millions of people enjoy that and spend a lot of money doing it. Now, if you're watching it because you enjoy watching people get hurt, the intention there is maybe what's unhealthy, rather than watching it for entertainment for other
在我看来，在电影或电视节目中看到血腥场面与在现实生活中看到它之间有很大的区别。两者之间有很强的联系吗？恐怖和血腥，因为我不得不说，在我看来，想要观看这些血腥的东西似乎很不健康。所以您为什么要将两者联系起来？嗯，我认为对于很多不同的事情你都可以这么说，这取决于你观看它的动机，对吧？所以，假设我喜欢拳击或综合格斗（MMA），数以百万计的人喜欢它并花很多钱去看。现在，如果你观看是因为你喜欢看人受伤，那么这种意图可能是不健康的，而不是为了娱乐或其他
reasons. And I think the same thing could be said of sort of gory horror movies or sort of more disgust-based horror movies. Some of the things I've been looking into with perspective, like, why do people enjoy the gory aspects? Or at least, why are those interesting to us, right? Why is that sometimes we find things interesting, but we don't necessarily enjoy them. And I think with with gore, what it can be is that at least when it comes to my morbid curiosity scale, it seems to be that it's more about learning sort of the limitations of the body and learning about the consequences of interacting with something dangerous. And so you can imagine that if you're watching a horror movie and the protagonist comes
原因。我认为血腥恐怖电影或基于厌恶感的恐怖电影也可以这么说。我一直在研究的一些关于视角的问题，比如，为什么人们喜欢血腥的方面？或者至少，为什么这些对我们来说很有趣，对吧？为什么有时我们觉得某些事物很有趣，但并不一定喜欢它们。我认为对于血腥，至少在我的病态好奇心量表上，它似乎更多是关于学习身体的局限性，以及了解与危险事物互动所带来的后果。所以你可以想象，如果你在看一部恐怖电影，主角
across a dead body, and the dead body has, you know, maybe a small cut on its neck, that doesn't give you a lot of information about the killer, right? It doesn't instill a lot of fear in you because anybody could cut another person's neck. It doesn't require a lot of strength or stealth or anything like that. But if their protagonist is walking along and they come across a body that's, you know, missing both of its arms and has its head smashed in, that then causes you to imagine something much more ferocious and terrifying and awful. And so, again, according to some of the studies that I've done and others have done, gruesome injuries seem to index formidability really well.
遇到了一具尸体，而尸体脖子上可能有一个小伤口，这并不能给你提供关于凶手的很多信息，对吧？它不会让你感到太多的恐惧，因为任何人都可以割开别人的脖子。这不需要太多的力量、隐蔽性或类似的东西。但如果主角走着走着遇到了一具尸体，它失去了双臂，头也被砸碎了，那就会让你想象出更凶猛、更可怕、更糟糕的事情。所以，根据我和其他人做的一些研究，血腥的伤口似乎能很好地衡量“威慑力”。
And so if someone can cause more damage to you, they're typically more dangerous, larger, scarier, and more of a threat. And so I think that horror stories often use gore as a kind of index of how terrifying and threatening the monster actually is. And so it's kind of a foreshadowing sometimes, or if you've already seen the monster, it might just be a clear example of how dangerous the thing you're dealing with is. And so in that way, I think it actually ties into this idea that you're interested in dangerous, potential dangers or threats, right?
所以如果某人能对你造成更大的伤害，他们通常就更危险、更强大、更可怕，威胁也更大。所以我认为恐怖故事经常使用血腥场面作为衡量怪物实际上有多可怕和多具威胁性的一种指标。所以它有时是一种预示，或者如果你已经见过怪物了，它可能只是一个明确的例子，说明你正在处理的东西有多危险。因此，我认为它实际上与“你对危险、潜在威胁感兴趣”这一观点联系在一起，对吧？
Because the Gore indexes how threatening or how dangerous the monster might be. So what does it mean if somebody scores a five on your test? Is that a sign of possible psychopathy? No, I don't think so. You know, it's not a, I should say, you know, it's not a clinical test, right? It's not a, it's not meant to diagnose you with anything. There are plenty of people who score fives that are perfectly healthy. And there are plenty of people who score ones who are probably not perfectly healthy.
因为血腥程度衡量了怪物可能有多具威胁性或多危险。那么如果有人在您的测试中得了5分意味着什么？这是精神病态的迹象吗？不，我不这么认为。你知道，我应该说，它不是一个临床测试，对吧？它不是为了诊断你患有任何疾病。有很多得5分的人是非常健康的。也有很多得1分的人可能并不完全健康。
And so I don't think that, at least in the studies that I've done, you know, morbid curiosity does not seem to indicate any kind of pathological trait, right? Just because you're high or low in morbid curiosity does not seem to correlate strongly with any kind of pathological traits. Then how do you suggest other researchers use the scale, if not for that? Well, I think it can tell us a lot about why humans do the weird things they do. I think morbid curiosity probably explains a lot of our entertainment choices. I think it explains, potentially could explain a lot of themes and things like religion. You know, if you go through a lot of religions and mythology, there's a lot of violence and death and scary things that go. on. And it's kind of a curious thing that in stories where you would imagine people want to have,
所以我认为，至少在我所做的研究中，病态好奇心似乎并不指向任何病理特征，对吧？仅仅因为你的病态好奇心高或低，似乎并不能与任何病理特征有强烈的相关性。那么，如果不是为了那个目的，您建议其他研究人员如何使用这个量表呢？嗯，我认为它可以告诉我们很多关于人类为什么会做那些奇怪事情的原因。我认为病态好奇心可能解释了我们很多娱乐选择。我认为它可能解释了宗教中的许多主题和事物。你知道，如果你研究很多宗教和神话，里面有很多暴力、死亡和可怕的事情。这是一种奇怪的事情，在那些你认为人们想要
want to escape reality and have this purely pleasant experience. And yet there's, there are no stories that I can think of, whether they're written or oral or audiovisual, where it's just a happy story, right? There's always some kind of tragedy and often some kind of threat that goes on. Right. And that kind of mirrors, I think, the human experience that, you know, life is not this just pure, easy, joyful thing. There are things that we have to overcome. There are challenges. There are threats. And certainly that has been true historically, more so than it even is now. And so I think stories, you know, do a good job of showing how people can overcome these kinds of scary things. And so the morbid curiosity scale is a great
逃避现实并获得纯粹愉快体验的故事中，却没有任何故事——无论是书面、口头还是视听形式——是纯粹快乐的故事，对吧？总会有某种悲剧，而且通常会有某种威胁。没错。我认为这反映了人类的经验，即生活不是纯粹、简单、快乐的事情。我们必须克服一些事情。有挑战，有威胁。当然，从历史上看，这一点比现在更真实。所以我认为故事在展示人们如何克服这些可怕的事情方面做得很好。因此，病态好奇心量表是一个很好的
way to capture people's kind of inherent interest in that. And because it seems to be a widely distributed trait. I think that, you know, there's a lot of room to better understand what it could lead to and what it's related to, what other personality traits or potentially pathological traits, or potentially beneficial traits or beneficial things that could be related to. Let's talk for a minute about kids and fear. You've written that in general, it's good for kids to experience scary play. Why is that and what's the balance? between things that are healthy, scary, and things that are going to give children nightmares for weeks or months. Well, you know, one of the key hallmarks of juvenile mammals broadly is play, right?
方式来捕捉人们对此的内在兴趣。而且因为它似乎是一种广泛分布的特质，我认为还有很大的空间去更好地理解它可能导致什么，它与什么相关，它与其他人格特质或潜在的病理特质，或者潜在的有益特质或有益事物有什么联系。让我们花点时间谈谈孩子和恐惧。您写道，总的来说，让孩子体验惊悚游戏是有益的。为什么会这样？在健康的恐惧和会让孩子做几周或几个月噩梦的事情之间，平衡点在哪里？嗯，你知道，幼年哺乳动物的一个关键标志就是玩耍，对吧？
And in most cases, juvenile mammals engage in different kinds of rough and tumble or even what you might call scary play. They chase each other, they hide from each other, they explore new terrain that they're unfamiliar with. they, you know, lose their, they engage in vestibular play where they sort of lose their sense of direction or they're going too fast and spinning and they can't walk straight. For example, kids love to spin around and then try to walk, right? Yeah. Why is that fun? Well, it kind of throws you out of your element and it teaches you how to quickly regain
在大多数情况下，幼年哺乳动物会进行各种各样的打闹，甚至是你可能称之为“惊悚游戏”的活动。它们互相追逐，互相躲藏，探索它们不熟悉的陌生地形。它们进行前庭觉游戏，在那里它们会失去方向感，或者跑得太快、旋转，导致无法走直线。例如，孩子们喜欢转圈然后尝试走路，对吧？是的。为什么这很有趣？嗯，它让你脱离了舒适区，它教会你如何在面对不确定的事物时迅速恢复
composure in the face of something that's uncertain, how to overcome things that seem scary. So if you're out playing and you're climbing a tree and it feels very scary. but your friends maybe are egging you on to keep going higher, or maybe you just want to go higher so you can see what's up there. These kinds of play teach kids how to manage their emotions, because if you go through your entire life, always avoiding any kind of a negative emotion, you're eventually going to have a negative emotion occur, right?
镇定，如何克服那些看起来很可怕的事情。所以如果你在外面玩，正在爬树，感觉非常害怕，但你的朋友可能在怂恿你继续往上爬，或者也许你只是想爬得更高，看看上面有什么。这些游戏教会孩子们如何管理自己的情绪，因为如果你一生中总是避免任何负面情绪，你最终还是会遇到负面情绪，对吧？
Like something bad will eventually happen. And if you've never experienced fear before or anxiety before, in a safe setting, you're going to feel really unprepared for it and you're going to be really surprised and shocked to not know how to handle those kinds of feelings. And so, you know, these kind of scary play or adventurous play or risky or thrilling play,
比如坏事最终会发生。如果你从未在安全的环境中体验过恐惧或焦虑，你就会感到非常没有准备，并且会因为不知道如何处理这些感觉而感到非常惊讶和震惊。所以，你知道，这种惊悚游戏、冒险游戏或冒险、刺激的游戏，
there's quite a bit of evidence that it's good for kids and can teach them emotion regulation, self-competence, and just kind of help them grow as, you know, young learners that the kids are. Now, there's a stereotype that horror fans must be cold-hearted and lack empathy. But you've done some research that's contradicted that. Can you talk about it? What did you find? Yeah, this is this is another one of those things that came out of a handful of studies in the 1980s in psychology journals showing that,
有相当多的证据表明它对孩子有好处，可以教会他们情绪调节、自我胜任感，并帮助他们成长为年轻的学习者。现在有一种刻板印象，认为恐怖片粉丝一定是冷酷无情、缺乏同理心的。但您做了一些研究反驳了这一点。您能谈谈吗？您发现了什么？是的，这是80年代心理学期刊中少数几项研究得出的结论之一，显示
well, horror fans are just these adrenaline junkies with no empathy. And, you know, being a horror fan myself and knowing lots of horror fans and having gone to various conventions and haunted houses and things, it certainly didn't ring true with my intuition and with my experience, right, which is not a good place to build scientific data, but it is a good place to build hypotheses. And so I decided to look into this a little more, and I've conducted some studies recently looking at, like you mentioned, cold-heartedness, which is kind of, you can think of it as the opposite of compassion, right? You just have no care for another person's well-being.
恐怖片粉丝只是没有同理心的肾上腺素瘾君子。而且，作为一个恐怖片粉丝，认识很多恐怖片粉丝，并去过各种大会、鬼屋和类似的地方，这肯定与我的直觉和经验不符，对吧？虽然这不是建立科学数据的最佳场所，但它是建立假设的好地方。所以我决定深入研究一下，我最近进行了一些研究，正如你提到的，关于“冷酷无情”，你可以把它看作是同情心的对立面，对吧？你只是根本不在乎他人的福祉。
And what I found is that people who are morbidly curious and people who enjoy horror movies tend to actually be lower in cold-heartedness than those who don't enjoy them. That is, they have greater compassion. And with respect to empathy, which is a slightly different measure, but similar and complementary in some ways, I just have a paper right now that's soon to be published in Journal of Media Psychology. And it's kind of a multi-study paper showing that horror fans actually. don't have any different levels of empathy, whether it's effective or cognitive, than anyone else who doesn't enjoy horror.
我发现，那些有病态好奇心的人和喜欢恐怖电影的人，实际上在冷酷无情方面的得分往往比那些不喜欢的人要低。也就是说，他们有更多的同情心。关于同理心，这是一个略有不同的衡量标准，但在某些方面是相似且互补的。我刚刚有一篇论文即将发表在《媒体心理学杂志》上。这是一篇多项研究论文，显示恐怖片粉丝实际上
And so part of the reason this might deviate from past studies is that in those studies in the 80s, they would often, you know, the stimuli would be, for example, just a murder scene from a horror movie. So you just show someone a two to three minute clip of the killer killing someone and ask the participant how much they enjoyed it. Well, if you take that as a measure of how much you enjoy horror movies, you probably are going to find that people who are low in empathy enjoy it more, right? It would be like if I showed someone just a breakup scene from a rom-com and I asked them,
在同理心水平上——无论是情感上的还是认知上的——与任何不喜欢恐怖片的人没有任何区别。部分原因可能是它偏离了过去的研究，因为在80年代的那些研究中，刺激物通常只是恐怖电影中的谋杀场景。所以你只是给某人看两到三分钟杀手杀人的片段，然后问参与者他们有多喜欢它。好吧，如果你把这作为衡量一个人有多喜欢恐怖电影的标准，你很可能会发现那些同理心低的人更喜欢它，对吧？这就像如果我给某人看浪漫喜剧中的分手场景，然后问他们，
how much did you enjoy this? And I take that answer to be how much people enjoy rom-coms. It's probably not going to tell me much about how much people enjoy rom-coms. Or certainly it's not going to tell me much about the fans of romantic comedies. But it might tell me something about status, right? It's going to tell me something about people who enjoy watching others in pain. And so I think part of what happened was that the stimuli were just a little bit, they weren't operationalized very well, you know, because people had this assumption that you must enjoy horror movies for the violence specifically and for the harm to others. And so they took that, they took the stimuli that matched that and it sort of confirmed their own bias in some ways. But it turns out, you know, if you show people full-length movies or if you take different measures like how many horror movies they've seen, you get it. different answers on whether or not they are very empathetic.
你有多喜欢这个？然后我把这个答案当作人们喜欢浪漫喜剧的程度。这可能无法告诉我人们有多喜欢浪漫喜剧。或者肯定无法告诉我关于浪漫喜剧粉丝的任何信息。但这可能会告诉我关于“状态”的一些信息，对吧？它会告诉我关于那些喜欢看别人痛苦的人的一些信息。所以我认为发生的部分原因是刺激物没有被很好地操作化，你知道，因为人们有一种假设，认为你必须专门为了暴力和对他人的伤害而喜欢恐怖电影。所以他们采用了符合这一点的刺激物，这在某种程度上证实了他们自己的偏见。但事实证明，如果你给人们看完整长度的电影，或者采取不同的衡量标准，比如他们看过多少部恐怖电影，你会得到
Are there other personality traits or characteristics that morbid, morbidly curious people tend to share? Like, have you looked at the Big Five, for example? Yeah, it's actually not that strongly correlated with the Big Five, which is another reason I think it's an important measure to kind of look at in the future, because the Big Five does capture a wide range of variance and in a lot of different life circumstances and other individual differences. And it varies a bit from population to population and different ages. It varies a bit.
不同的答案，关于他们是否非常有同理心。还有其他病态好奇心强的人倾向于共享的人格特质或特征吗？比如，您研究过“大五人格”吗？是的，它实际上与“大五人格”的相关性并不是那么强，这也是我认为它是一个值得在未来研究的重要衡量标准的原因之一，因为“大五人格”确实捕捉到了广泛的差异，以及在许多不同的生活环境和其他个体差异中的表现。它在不同人群和不同年龄段之间会有所变化。它会有所波动。
But in general, it's somewhat associated with higher openness from time to time. So, for example, people who enjoy horror movies tend to be a little bit higher in openness, sometimes also higher in neuroticism. So they're a bit more anxious, maybe experience negative feelings a bit more. One of the traits that is commonly associated with is rebelliousness, which is maybe not surprising because it also tends to be younger people who enjoy horror movies and younger people tend to be more rebellious. So there's probably some collinearity going on there.
但总的来说，它有时与更高的“开放性”相关联。例如，喜欢恐怖电影的人往往在“开放性”上稍高一些，有时在“神经质”上也更高。所以他们稍微焦虑一点，也许更容易体验到负面情绪。它通常关联的特质之一是“叛逆性”，这也许并不令人惊讶，因为喜欢恐怖电影的人往往也更年轻，而年轻人往往更叛逆。所以那里可能存在一些共线性。
Some other traits, you would think that it would be associated with low disgust, but actually morbid curiosity is not that strongly correlated with low disgust. And it could be because, again, disgust is one of those traits where it's difficult to operationalize. You know, there's disgust from bodily injuries, which is something that morbidly curious people would certainly be low in. But then there's disgust from other kinds of things that have nothing to do with threats. And those are much less associated with how morbidly curious you are. Is there a connection between morbid curiosity and our dream life? Do people who are morbidly curious tend to have more nightmares or scary dreams than other people?
至于其他特质，你可能会认为它与“低厌恶感”相关，但实际上病态好奇心与“低厌恶感”的相关性并不那么强。这可能是因为，同样，厌恶感是那种难以操作化的特质之一。你知道，有来自身体伤害的厌恶感，病态好奇心强的人肯定在这方面得分较低。但还有其他与威胁无关的事物的厌恶感。而那些与你的病态好奇心程度的相关性要小得多。病态好奇心与我们的梦境生活之间有联系吗？病态好奇心强的人是否比其他人更容易做噩梦或做恐怖的梦？
I would love to conduct that study. So if anyone listening would love to do it, I would have to do it. I would love to know. I've had this idea that maybe, and this is, you know, hypothesis, speculation, but I've written about it a little bit, this idea that nightmares might be sort of the original form of morbid curiosity, right? And there's a great, there's a great program of study by this, I believe he's Finnish philosopher and cognitive neuroscientist.
我很想进行那项研究。所以如果任何听众想做这个，我必须得做。我很想知道。我一直有这个想法，也许——这只是假设、推测，但我写过一点——这个想法是：噩梦可能是病态好奇心的原始形式，对吧？有一位伟大的研究者，我相信他是芬兰的哲学家和认知神经科学家。
His last name is Ravonsuo. I think his name is Auntie Ravonsuo. And he's come up with this idea that, you know, if you think of dreaming, you have to imagine, like, well, why did that evolve? Right. Why do humans have, and potentially other animals, have this ability to dream? Because, you know, there's some speculation that, well, maybe it's just random firing in your, you know, the neurons in your brain. But if you think about it, I mean, dreams are sort of directed in some way. You know, they're weird, but they do have some kind of story to them.
他的姓是拉冯苏（Ravonsuo）。我想他的名字是安蒂·拉冯苏。他提出了一个观点，即如果你思考做梦，你必须想象，好吧，为什么它会进化出来？对吧？为什么人类——以及潜在的其他动物——拥有这种做梦的能力？因为，你知道，有一些推测认为，好吧，也许这只是你大脑中神经元的随机放电。但如果你仔细想想，我的意思是，梦在某种程度上是有导向的。你知道，它们很奇怪，但它们确实有一些故事性。
They do have, you know, the visuals are often vivid. They might be a bit fantasy oriented, but they do seem real, right? And so that suggests some kind of order and some kind of directedness to it. And so his idea is that, well, maybe dreaming is a way to rehearse things that happen in the real world while you're, you know, you spend eight hours a night, you know, ideally a third of your life sleeping, right? And that's a lot of time lost when you could be gathering resources or finding mates or, you know, doing things that help you. you in the waking world. And so his idea was that, well, maybe dreaming is a way to kind of capitalize on this downtime.
它们确实有，你知道，视觉效果通常很生动。它们可能有点偏向幻想，但它们看起来确实很真实，对吧？所以这表明它有一定的秩序和某种导向性。所以他的观点是，好吧，也许做梦是一种在现实世界中排练事情的方式，当你，你知道，你每晚花八个小时，理想情况下是你生命的三分之一在睡觉，对吧？当你本可以收集资源、寻找配偶或做一些对你有帮助的事情时，这浪费了很多时间。所以他的想法是，好吧，也许做梦是一种利用这段停机时间的方式。
And it's a way to simulate potential experiences. And if so, then it would be really, really adaptive to be able to simulate threats. And again, for the same reason that it might be useful to engage in scary play, it could be useful to simulate these kinds of threats in your dreams and then practice or rehearse your responses to them. There's some evidence that, for example, during COVID, the early, might be able to months of COVID-19, people were having more nightmares, certainly more pandemic-related dreams. So they were kind of dreaming about this new threat, right?
这是一种模拟潜在体验的方式。如果是这样的话，那么能够模拟威胁将是非常、非常有适应性的。同样，出于与参与惊悚游戏可能有用相同的原因，在梦中模拟这些威胁并练习或排练你对它们的反应可能是有用的。有一些证据表明，例如，在新冠疫情期间，早期，可能是新冠疫情的头几个月，人们确实做了更多的噩梦，当然更多的是与大流行相关的梦。所以他们是在梦中模拟这种新的威胁，对吧？
They were kind of dreaming about potential problems that they might be facing. And so it's possible that, you know, dreaming or nightmares are kind of their very early form of morbid curiosity in humans and potentially in other animals. Speaking of the pandemic-related movies that we've seen over the last few years, for some people, they feel that they're too soon or too close to home. Why is it that some people find them therapeutic while others are not ready to relive it in the form of entertainment? Yeah. That's a, yeah, it's a tough question to answer. Again, one of those areas that is so ready for people to dive in, unfortunately, I only have so much bandwidth. And so I've only, I've conducted a few studies
他们是在梦中模拟他们可能面临的潜在问题。所以，做梦或噩梦可能是人类以及潜在的其他动物身上病态好奇心的非常早期的形式。说到过去几年我们看到的与大流行相关的电影，对一些人来说，他们觉得这些电影太早了，或者太贴近现实了。为什么有些人觉得它们具有治疗作用，而另一些人却还没有准备好以娱乐的形式重温它？是的。这是一个很难回答的问题。同样，这也是那些非常适合人们深入研究的领域之一，不幸的是，我的精力有限。所以我只进行了一些研究
on this. But as far as why some people find it useful or therapeutic and others don't, I think that's a huge question that should be answered. Because if we could figure that out, I mean, we might open up new avenues for therapy, for things for anxiety or for difficult life circumstances or PTSD. There's pretty good now, I think, empirical evidence, even that some people do use fictional scary events or scary play to help them deal with real scary events. And it's not clear to me or I think anyone else yet why this works for some people or in some
关于这一点。但至于为什么有些人觉得它有用或具有治疗作用，而另一些人则不然，我认为这是一个巨大的问题，应该得到解答。因为如果我们能弄清楚这一点，我们可能会为焦虑或困难的生活环境或创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）开辟新的治疗途径。我认为现在已经有相当好的实证证据表明，有些人确实利用虚构的恐怖事件或惊悚游戏来帮助他们应对现实中可怕的事件。目前还不清楚为什么这对某些人或在某些
circumstances and maybe not for others or in other circumstances. So I think that's probably, in my opinion, the area of research around morbid curiosity that's most ripe, most ready for research and has the potential to impact people's lives the most. So you mentioned that you are a horror fan, or are you a Halloween aficionado as well? I am a Halloween aficionado. In fact, the town that I live in has a, it's a kind of a tourist town, and it has a lot, it has lots of events throughout the year, but the biggest event of the year is their Halloween parade or their Halloween event. And it's actually a zombie crawl, and I'm the organizer of it. So I organized this huge, uh, uh,
情况下有效，而对其他人或在其他情况下可能无效。所以我认为，在我看来，围绕病态好奇心的研究领域是最成熟、最值得研究，并且最有潜力对人们的生活产生最大影响的领域。那么您提到您是恐怖片粉丝，您也是万圣节爱好者吗？我是万圣节爱好者。事实上，我住的那个镇是一个旅游小镇，全年有很多活动，但一年中最大的活动是他们的万圣节游行或万圣节活动。它实际上是一个“僵尸爬行”活动，我是它的组织者。所以我组织了这个巨大的，呃，
This is in Denmark? No, this is in the Ozarks. This is in Eureka Springs, Arkansas. Oh, okay. And it's called the Eureka Springs Zombie Crawl. And it's a day-long event where people come and there's spooky music and spooky vendors and dancing. And everybody is dressed up as zombies of some kind. And right around dusk, we have a big, huge, you know, thousands of people engage in this zombie crawl where they crawl through the streets and people have their apocalyptic cars driving to the streets.
这是在丹麦吗？不，这是在欧扎克山脉。这是在阿肯色州的尤里卡斯普林斯。噢，好的。它被称为“尤里卡斯普林斯僵尸爬行”。这是一个为期一天的活动，人们会来参加，有恐怖的音乐、恐怖的摊贩和舞蹈。每个人都打扮成各种僵尸。就在黄昏时分，我们有一个巨大的，你知道，成千上万的人参与这个僵尸爬行，他们在街上爬行，人们开着他们的末日风格汽车在街上行驶。
And it's kind of this way to embrace, you know, these scary things and play with them in a safe way. It's a kid-friendly event. Kids come and I get a lot of questions like, you know, will my kid be scared? And I mean, the real answer to that is I don't know, right? But I can say that a lot of kids do come. And it helps when children see, you know, the monster transforming. If you watch them putting on makeup, it helps them understand that this is just play. Right.
这是一种以安全方式拥抱并探索那些可怕事物的方法。这是一个适合儿童的活动。孩子们会来参加，我经常被问到：我的孩子会害怕吗？老实说，我也不知道。但我可以说，很多孩子确实会来。当孩子们看到怪物在变身时，这会有所帮助。如果你看着他们化妆，这能帮助他们理解这只是一种游戏，对吧。
It's like a dog wagging its tail to another. dog. It's kind of a signal that we're just engaging in play. And so that does help children, I think, kind of overcome their immediate first response to this person walking around with flesh falling off of their face. You know, it's a, it's a way for them to understand that not everything is always as it seems. So any big questions that you still want to answer research-wise? Oh, so many. I mean, you know, when I first started, so I, I graduated with my PhD just in 2022. And when I first started doing work on morbid curiosity during my PhD,
就像狗对另一只狗摇尾巴一样，这是一种我们在进行游戏的信号。我认为这确实能帮助孩子们克服看到一个脸上皮肉脱落的人走来走去时的第一反应。这是一种让他们理解事物并不总是表面看起来那样的方式。那么，在研究方面，还有什么你想回答的大问题吗？哦，太多了。我是在2022年才获得博士学位的。当我刚开始研究病态好奇心时，
nobody was doing that. I mean, nobody was, was publishing on it. There was no operational definition of it. I mean, it was like this untouched thing in science, which was weird to me because it was something that every person I talked to
根本没有人做这方面的研究。我的意思是，没有人发表过相关论文，也没有对其进行过操作性定义。这在科学界几乎是一片空白，这让我感到很奇怪，因为我交谈过的每个人
understood. When I told them I was studying that, they understood some sense of what that meant. And they had their own examples of this in their life, for their friends that were morbidly curious, but they weren't. I mean, everybody had this sense of,
都能理解这个概念。当我告诉他们我在研究这个课题时，他们都能理解其中的含义。他们生活中都有这样的例子，比如他们的朋友有病态好奇心，而他们自己却没有。每个人都有这种感觉，
of this being something that existed in the world. And yet, at least psychological science had not really touched it much. Now that I'm a few years out of that, and I've been publishing on it for four or five years, um, I get emails, you know,
觉得这是一种客观存在的事物。然而，至少心理科学界还没有怎么触及它。现在距离我开始研究已经过去几年了，我也已经发表了四五年的相关论文，我经常收到邮件，
weekly of students who are doing their master's thesis on it now, who are other people who I'm collaborating with. And so I think in the next like, five to 10 years, there's going to be a huge boon in research on this because everybody's kind of doing that research right now. I think in part, because the pandemic, for example, I think woke a lot of people up to this idea that, you know, real disasters can happen, not just to anyone, but to me, right? Like this, the scary, apocalyptic, almost like things can happen not just in the movies, but in the real world. And I think it's woken people up to this
每周都有学生写信说他们正在做相关的硕士论文，或者有人想与我合作。所以我认为在未来五到十年内，这方面的研究将会迎来巨大的繁荣，因为现在每个人都在做这方面的研究。我认为部分原因是疫情让很多人意识到，真正的灾难不仅会发生在别人身上，也可能发生在自己身上。那种可怕的、末日般的场景不仅会出现在电影里，也会发生在现实世界中。我认为这让人们意识到，
idea that, you know, maybe being curious about these kinds of things and being interested in them, in them is not necessarily such a bad thing. I think as far as, you know, the most pertinent questions or the most interesting questions, I mean, I think certainly the one that I had mentioned earlier in our chat about who seems to benefit from this and why and under what circumstances, I think that has the most potential for therapeutic contexts and the most potential to impact people's lives. That would probably be the area that I think, you know, I would hope that a lot of, you know, clinicians and people like that would take seriously and do some studies on.
对这类事物感到好奇并产生兴趣，未必是一件坏事。至于最相关或最有趣的问题，我认为我之前提到的关于谁能从中受益、为什么受益以及在什么情况下受益的问题，最有潜力应用于治疗环境，也最有潜力影响人们的生活。这可能是我希望临床医生和其他相关专业人士能够认真对待并进行研究的领域。
Well, Dr. Scrivener, I want to thank you for joining me today. It was really interesting chatting with you. Thanks. Yeah, thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology. APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyion. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好的，斯克里夫纳博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。与您交谈非常有趣。谢谢。是的，谢谢。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 以及任何您获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》往期节目。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 SpeakingofPsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目，我是金·米尔斯。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。